of course last night i said uh that we
will be wrapping up
our time here at turner uh it's almost
11 years i think
uh and we're going to be wrapping it up
on june 24th
and so um you know we've had an
absolutely delightful time here uh
with the turner folks they've let us do
whatever we wanted
we've had a joyous time there's so much
stuff that we've made that i'm really
proud of
so we're gonna be revisiting a lot of
that in the next uh
you know six weeks or so we'll be
showing
you some of those moments we'll have
some surprises really looking forward to
it
but the point that i wanted to get to
is that when you've been in late night
television as long as i have
day in and day out and it's really it's
28 years
at this point which is just
mind-boggling to me when you put in that
kind of time
you start to wonder what's my
what's my legacy how do people think of
me
how will i be remembered and thought of
in the great pantheon
of uh comedic television hosts
you know i know it sounds like navel
gazing and self-absorbed but it's just
what people do
it's just human nature well i got my
answer
last week i was watching jeopardy and
uh well this happened take a look
recent books for 800 a head writer of
saturday night live he titled his memoir
a very punchable face kelly who's conan
o'brien
that's incorrect
looking for colin jost
do you like that andy you like that you
having a good laugh
a little laugh what the hell is that
the guy has fed two clues wrote for
sarnot live
and has a face you want to punch
[Laughter]
not even hesitation bang conan o'brien
and then nobody else can come up with
anyone right
no one he gives anderson cooper gave
them plenty of time
conan that's the face you'd want to
punch
i feel real bad for colin joseph i do
too he probably worked real hard on that
book
[Laughter]
so many people bought that book thinking
it was my book
oh boy a conan o'brien book i've been
waiting for this one
god i'd like to punch his fat face
the hell is that that's what's great
about no matter how long you've been in
late night no matter what you think
you've
accomplished a little moment like that
brings you not
just right back down to earth but it
digs a hole and
shoves you in it yeah
[Laughter]
whose face do you want to punch going to
brian